on a besoin de débat et pas d'un grand
centre où tout se vaut dray moi je crois
que tout ne se vaut pas est ce que on
peut dire aujourd'hui que manuel macron
a tué cette gauche et sa droite c'est
trop con côté mais je le crois pas elle
était anesthésié en tout cas pour ce qui
est de la gauche parce que elle sort
d'une défaite qui est considérable mais
enfin elle est fidèle à ses valeurs à
ses convictions dans l'histoire une
histoire longue de la gauche elle a ses
combats et aujourd'hui on est une
opposition qui est une opposition
intransigeante quand il y va de la
justice de l'égalité les principes
républicains
une gauche responsable parce qu'on ne
propose pas n'importe quoi non les
propositions que nous formulons nos
amendements que nous déposons et puis
une gauche imaginative parce que vous
les remparts a sans doute tout à l'heure
eh bien on formule des propositions qui
nous permet de regarder le monde de
demain non pas avec les lunettes d'hier
mais avec celle d'aujourd'hui